the rats are out in France during the
corona pandemic they've been thriving in
almost all major cities pest controller
and rat catcher Thierry bonda Works
non-stop he goes from seller to Cellar
laying out the poisoned rat bait
you can't have weak nerves in this job
at any moment a rat can jump out at you
and there are many more rats than before
the lockdowns the rat catchers were
confined to their homes leaving the
rodents to breed freely
beautiful rat beers eight to ten young
every two to three months in two years
that's more than one hundred thousand
rats it's a never-ending battle
[Applause]
in the picturesque Alsatian Metropolis
of Strasbourg the rats have also enjoyed
optimal conditions due to the pandemic
numbers have surged and they are
everywhere
it's a plague Strasbourg is actually
quite clean but it's a Pity that the
residents aren't more attentive
the rats must be annihilated I hate them
they frighten me bro
the infestation is particularly severe
here in the poorer quarters of
Strasbourg
[Music]
you see them over there they're
everywhere when you walk through the
neighborhood you see them at every
corner in the European capital of
Strasbourg the capital of Human Rights
it's a disgrace success
you can't go on like this
you can't have people living with rats
and cockroaches
[Applause]
has been living in this neighborhood for
30 years he is furious with the city
authorities
people here have to live among rats
they eat wires and cars and people have
already been bitten in the city council
they're discussing whether rats are
really harmful Earthly belong in our
ecosystem these people live on another
planet or they're crazy one of the two
bugatta Strikes Back by filming the rats
like here on a car engine and posting
the videos online
his social media success is forcing the
city of Strasbourg to act
councilor bonjamo Soleil doesn't want to
exterminate the rats but rather to force
them to stay underground starting at
this rubbish dump
yeah
which the rats came through so we put up
this great and now they can't get out
but as many residents complain it
doesn't get rid of the rats the City
Council Claims the problem is homemade
because the French cooked more during
the lockdown
there's a Corona effect people were
cooking much more at home and throwing
out the leftovers the restaurants were
closed it contributed to the rat
infestation
and that applies to the whole country
it's estimated today that for every
French city dweller there are almost two
rats and now they even have a political
Lobby the Strasbourg city council is
divided into Pro and Contra rat groups
these animals can't just go back to
living in the wild so they have no place
to go
the real question is how to help the
people not how to make the rats feel
more welcome
that's exactly what exterminated
thinks he has just completed further
training in more efficient methods for
combating rats
there will always be rats there are so
many houses social housing Estates we'll
always be needed
and now bodon and his colleagues are
putting their new knowledge into
practice so French rats could be facing
tougher times ahead
[Music]